the unions wanted you to abolish wanted
you to promote proposed the abolition of
zero hours contracts why didn't you do
that because most people who have zero
eyes contracts choose them and want them
they find that flexibility that fits
their lifestyle there is however an
issue about people who have been on long
term zero hours contracts and who would
like fixed hours and so we have a number
of recommendations which hopefully will
lead to more employers offering more
hours guaranteeing more hours to workers
but my general approach is not to use a
sledgehammer to crack a nut if a form of
employment whether it's gig work or zero
hours work is generally speaking one
that people choose to do we shouldn't
stop them doing it but we should make
sure they get their protections that
they need and also we should make sure
that the way in which those companies
are organized fits in with not just our
regulatory system both of our tax system
business sector it grubs you about some
of your proposals as well I mean the
you're proposing a premium for some
zero-hours workers they don't like that
and you're also doing the way you're
proposing doing the way with the Swedish
derogation Swedish terry-yes which
allows us off the time indeed so this is
basically giving temp workers the same
rights as permanent employees they don't
want that either
so let's look at both those proposals so
the first proposal is that which we have
referring to the low pay Commission is
that if you have a zero hours on low
hours contract you would get extra money
for the hours you're asked to work but
that you're not guaranteed and the aim
of that is it might put a bit more put
money into the pocket of people a
minimum wage but more importantly it
might encourage employers to think a bit
more creatively about how instead of
transferring all the risk onto the
shoulders of employees they might
guarantee those employees more hours
because if you are guaranteed no hours
are very few as it's hard to get a
mortgage it's hard to get a loan so
that's the first proposal in a way it's
a kind of notion of overtime that if
you're a minimum wage in you're asked to
work more hours and you're guaranteed
that you should get overtime payment the
second proposal is that the Swedish
derogation now what we guarantee in this
country is if you're an agency work and
you work for 12 weeks alongside another
workers permanent at the end of that 12
weeks you should get the same terms and
conditions as the person you're working
alongside unfortunately the Swedish
derogation which is in a way a way of
avoiding that
has been misused and we didn't just hear
from trade unions that have been misused
we heard from agents it's in fact
agencies said to us weaker asked by
employers to use this as a kind of
fiddle to avoid people getting these
rights and we don't particularly like
doing it so actually all the things
agencies can do they can carry on doing
but this this Swedish delegation has
been too widely abused and in fact I
asked employees organizations when I
talk to them about this some time ago to
tell me how an alternative means for
cracking down on this without getting
rid of it and they didn't come back to
me so I'm afraid getting rid of it is
the best emergent day one of the other
interesting recommendations you made you
point out that there is an uneven
treatment on taxation with twelve
self-employed and employed workers
Philip Hammond would agree with that
wholeheartedly what you want the the
playing field leveled but is that
realistic given the government's setback
on on this in the comments recently yeah
we've added our voice to many other
reports the murli's report many years
ago the IFS The Office of Budget
Responsibility all of whom recognized
that at the moment we probably tax
self-employed labour too little so if I
if you go back to the beginning of the
welfare state at that point the amount
of money we raised in tax from
self-employed labor was about two-thirds
of what we raised form the labour of
employed people it's now a third and as
that gap is growing bigger
self-employment has grown so probably
over the medium term we need to think
about how those of us who pay for a
labour pay a similar amount for
self-employed labour as we do for
employed lay but otherwise not only one
we've got hole in our finances it
creates perverse incentives people to
disguise employment to self-employment
to avoid that tax burden a very brief
last question do you think this is gonna
get off the runway given Teresa Mays
lack of a minority you know I'm
confident I've been up and down the
country talking about good work the
public like the idea of good work many
of these recommendations are supported
by trade unions or business
organisations once we get away from
carnie audio or the kind of the
ideological battle and focus on the
specifics I'm confident that a lot of
these ideas will be exempted as you
tailor long day for you you appreciate
appreciate you coming in thank you